le président sur le ministre qui donc
est en israël je sais du monsieur à
thann les chats collègues ma question
porte sur la compensation par l'état des
frais engagés par les communes au titre
de la scolarité obligatoire à 33 ans
en application de la loi pour une école
de la confiance du 26 juillet dernier
l'article 17 de cette loi prévoit que
cette compensation s'applique aussi bien
pour les frais engagés par les communes
pour les établissements publics que pour
les établissements privés sous contrat
dans ce second cas il peut s'agir de
communes qui ne finançait pas du tout
des maternelles privées avant
l'abaissement de l'âge de l'instruction
obligatoire ou bien de communes qui les
finançait déjà volontairement soit les
deux ciel et deux tiers d'entre elles
notre haute assemblée s'était prononcé
pour une prise en charge totale des
frais engagés par les communes qu'elle
ait participé ou non à l'accueil
scolarisation des enfants de moins de
trois ans auparavant
cette compensation garantissant seule
une égalité entre elles l'objectif était
d'assurer une mesure de justice entre
communes monsieur le ministre vous
semblez avait dans ce sens celui de
l'équité entre les communes puisque vous
avez déclaré lors du débat sur la loi de
finances pour 2020 que les communes
recevraient une compensation en cas de
hausse des dépenses obligatoires pour
les écoles maternelles et élémentaires
et que personne ne perdrait d'argent
dans la nouvelle configuration la
parution d'un décret et d'un arrêté le
dire en décembre dernier mérite votre
éclairage cas elle ne semble pas avoir
totalement dissipé les interrogations et
les craintes des élus sur le sujet
pourriez vous nous dire ce qu'il en est
exactement monsieur le ministre quel est
votre position allons nous vers une
mesure de justice je vous remercie